I compare myself every day to warm
Buffet I get comments from people who
are like love your humility Alex I don't
think I'm that humble of a guy being
real at least internally in my own head
I am reminded daily of my inadequacy on
the business game because like right now
we've moved up a level in terms of like
now we're doing deals now we're
investing in companies we're taking on
big risk we're writing checks like
Warren Buffett 90 billion dollars on the
trading made in apple in 2020. one move
how could I say that I'm good like even
if I was exceptional it's still going to
take 20 years to prove it and by that
point I'll probably have other guys who
were Titans at that point to remind me
of the fact that I'm not as good as them
in your estimation is the presence of an
ego something which artificially limits
the size of the vision of how high you
want to climb yeah 100 you cannot admit
death sits and say you're awesome at the
same time in my opinion I think it's the
Dunning Kruger effect which is like the
more you learn about something the more
you realize you don't know I think that
if you have a tiny subset of things that
you are studying and a tiny subset of
people you're comparing yourself to it's
really easy to feel awesome about
yourself